hello everybody my name is Marc Blair in
this past weekend we raised 110 thousand
dollars for crisis text line that is
absolutely astonishing thank you
everybody so much for joining the
charity livestream and thank you
everybody so much for donating to the
cause if you don't know about crisis
text line I'll leave a link in the
description below the links to their
website you can find out more about them
but I'm sure you know about it because I
blabbered endlessly about it and it was
fun it was so much fun to be there with
my friends and the whole gang was able
to participate and you guys were able to
play with us and it was just a lot of
fun and I know we haven't been doing
these charity livestreams regularly
enough but I guarantee you this is the
start of regular monthly charity
livestreams in fact Tyler and I are
going back home to Cincinnati and when
we are there we're hoping to join Bob
and Wade in a Cincinnati reunion charity
livestream that should be oodles of fun
we just have to set up a few things but
that will be next month and we're
probably gonna do a Christmas theme to
it and also I want to do a 12 days of
Christmas video thing that we're gonna
be doing next month but that's getting
ahead of myself because I wanted to talk
about this week's videos and by the
title of this video which is probably
something along the lines of embrace the
cringe um it was it was a lot of fun I'm
not knocking what we did at all but it's
just that thing about experimenting and
trying new things and you definitely
find the things that don't work and I
mentioned this on the live stream we
went out to a park and we met with you
guys and it was a great experience as it
always is but we tried something which
we probably shouldn't have tried so so
basically we went out to the park and it
was super awesome as it always is to
meet you guys and be able to do videos
with you guys and there's still another
video that we did from that session
that's going to come out later but one
of the things that we did do was attempt
the don't laugh challenge in public and
we discovered that that either that
doesn't work in general
or were just not funny which I'm more
inclined to believe the latter of the
two options there because something
about being in public versus
controlled environment like the office
is this vastly different because the
don't laugh challenge is supposed to be
kinda cringy because there's moments
where it doesn't work they don't laugh
and it's just hey okay that joke didn't
go anywhere gonna step away from the
awkwardness now you know that's that's
part of the experience but when you're
out in a park you don't get to escape
you know gives you run away when
something's bad because what the
weirdest thing was there was an audience
there you guys were there and you guys
don't wanna be mean so you kind of path
laugh but that's so much worse than just
dead silence because it's kind of funny
when a joke falls so flat on its face
that it's just crickets is all you can
hear and sometimes like that is funny in
and of itself and that's what makes the
don't laugh challenge good but when you
get a bad joke and then yeah that is the
death of comedy the death of everything
and I talked about on the livestream
that I was gonna play this and of course
I am because I'm not gonna shy away from
this one it didn't work and I'm gonna
show you how how not not work it you did
so this is this is what we're talking
about do that oh this is exactly what
we're talking about when we say that no
yeah I mean it'll work sometimes because
in the moment I guarantee you everyone
was there was like yeah that was a good
time but then when you watch it back
it's like uh we were so desperately
trying here we go
oh boy gotta go fast no no no I'm a
horse no no Moo I spent 1 hello no I got
a big one coming out
see the point is that in the moment a
good fit and not the moment it's it's
not 100% not give me all your labs I'll
do it I swear giving me laughs laughs
laughs no oh American Family Values Iran
agreement
tickle-tickle we're scoring twenty years
ago you were still a [ __ ] for scoring
20 years ago I could have a baby see it
works it works but venom does and war
her but it was still fun I'm not gonna
say this wasn't fun it's one of those
moments like if you ever see that video
if you ever see that video where the
world's worst like uh the world's worst
flash mob it's where they do Gangnam
style in the mall
oh I what am I talking about I just pull
it up it's it's it's this video and wait
it's this video where they're in the
mall and you see them like yeah it's
they just think oh my god it's just
they're not committing and that's the
problem they're like it's like half
committing it's the essence of all and
then this guy waiting in the wings like
there's so many people that are waiting
in the wings and then there's no
coordination and and that's exactly what
we had going on here but they probably
had fun they probably had a lot of fun
and then everyone watching was like ah
that's cute but then as soon as it gets
put on the internet it's unedited if
it's just a non-stop barrage of awkward
it gets pretty bad and that's kind of
what happened here and it's not any
fault of you guys it's only us it's only
it's
oh wait I want to talk about this guy
that guy right here
really the kid was really funny not for
good reasons but he was just funny
you call that life I just gotta say this
is oh my god
it was just it's the world saddest
countdown it is just it literally just
the world's saddest countdown this
somber yeah I hate to say that it's bad
because it was it was the kids like
deadpan jokes that almost actually made
me laugh cuz he said he's at what the
first one was like what do you call a
squirrel that flies flying squirrel is
waved he delivered it was really funny
to me and then the next one was what do
you call a guy on the ground a dead guy
this is a cool thing yeah they aren't
bad jokes they're anti jokes and those
are funny
whereas bad jokes or not is this there's
a distinct difference it's like that
Brian Regan joke where he said we're a
sunset how come how come dinosaurs can't
talk well I don't know cuz they're all
dead
also I want to mention that Ethan spit
on my face right here if you watch here
comes the sad sad countdown
spit right on my face right after the
countdown it was a good end to the video
it really was but uh man is this silly
anyway I uh I don't have enough time to
show you the entire video but trust me
the rest is just exactly as that bags
like it's so fun like I I don't want to
knock this in anyway it's not not fun to
go out here and do this stuff with you
guys but there's just a line to cross in
terms of making a video out of it and
putting it up on the internet because
Katherine was trying to edit that one
and then Katherine was just like going
up to music hot fart is not for me and I
go like oh it can't be that bad
oh my god I'm not funny like we gonna
need hay we couldn't even hide behind
the shield of awkward it's to try to
make it a good video cuz cuz we could
not put that up and go here you go
everybody this is funny right
haha so the only way that we can talk
about it is in the sense that we know it
was not good so anyway that is uh that
is the story of that but oddly enough
that's the way that Ethan was telling me
about the other video the one that we
did put up the don't laugh challenge
that we did because Ethan told me
there's not funny either and then we all
gathered around and watched it and we
could not catch our breaths because we
were laughing so hard it was so
incredibly funny to us because it was
the perfect blend of awkward cringe enos
with actual fuckness does the
spontaneity the improvisation of it
makes for a really fun video and that's
why I love those types of videos but
that does not mean that I won't be doing
to try not to laugh challenge which is
gonna come again very soon I've got a
stockpile of videos I just got to go
through them again maybe I'll try to
incorporate uh you guys component to
that too but I don't know there's a lot
of holidays stuff coming up but we do
aim to get out there with you guys a lot
more so that is the wrap-up for this
week we've had just a ton of fun and I'm
super happy with the way things have
been going because I
more motivated than ever to just get
videos done and I'm like honored that
I've got so many cool people around me
that want to push me to be better and
and make better videos and just get out
there and do stuff every day and try new
things
I don't regret trying this new thing
I don't regret trying even if it turns
out to be bad I do not regret trying and
that's something that I would encourage
you guys to go out and do because in
this regard we failed but fear of
failure shouldn't be something that
dissuades you from trying new things and
going out there and expanding your
horizons because you never know what's
actually gonna work until you go out
there and do it and I guarantee you
there's some people that are funnier
than we are that could have made that
work just not us and not then so either
way thank you everybody so much for
watching look forward to another charity
livestream next month with even more
friends it should be super awesome and
hopefully back in Cincinnati and look
forward to Bob and Wade coming out here
to visit very soon so thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye-bye